-Our first guest tonight is
an Academy Award-nominated
actress and entrepreneur
you know from her work
in films like "Almost Famous,"
"Mona Lisa and the Blood Moon,"
and "How to Lose a Guy
in 10 Days."
She stars In "Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery,"
which premieres on Netflix,
December 23rd.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Kate Hudson,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
-Hi!
-It is so lovely
to have you here in person.
-It's nice to be here
with an audience.
-Yes, the last time you were
here in person,
there was nobody in the seats.
-There was no audience.
-So, thank you so much
for suffering through that,
and now your reward.
-I'm so happy.
I love an audience.
-You get a nice
Christmas audience.
-I love that you do
a guest drummer,
because my son Bing
is a drummer.
Like, been drumming
since he was a year old.
-And now, a year old, who --
did you guys get him a drum kit?
Because I feel like
that's a very cruel gift
to give another person's child.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we got him
the drum kit, but he --
-How do you know, at one,
that he wanted it?
-Because he took -- So, his dad
is in a band called Muse.
And Dom Howard, the drummer,
had to drumstick.
He couldn't even walk.
He took the drumsticks,
and that was it.
They've never left his hands.
-Really?
-He's 11 years old. He's insane.
Can he be a guest drummer
one day?
-I would love to have that.
We are gonna have to have him
submit a demo tape.
-Okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-But, this is very --
So, again, obviously,
you know, he's got music
in his bloodline.
But could you -- Did you guys
have an ear for it right away?
Were you were like, "Oh, he's
actually maybe gonna have
some talent?"
Like, at what point --
Be honest now --
don't be like,
"At one, we could tell."
-It was like 18 months.
He would, like, sit
and he would --
he would put pillows and
he'd do different heights.
And it was like --
[ Mimicking drumming ]
And we're like,
"What's happening?"
-I mean, if you got him
to play drums on pillows,
you're [Bleep] geniuses.
[ Laughter ]
-It was crazy.
-That's very impressive.
-And now, just recently, because
he's the kind of kid who goes,
"Mom, I'm gonna go play drums"
four times a day.
So, he goes --
And I had to, like --
You know, when you have a kid
like that,
it's, like, you want to
support that as much as you can.
And so the pool house,
which is more like a shed,
became the drum room.
And so that's Bing's room,
which all the other siblings
are jealous
because he has his own room.
-Yeah.
-And then Ryder plays guitar --
his older brother.
And Bing just decided --
Ryder went to college.
Bing just decided,
"Well, you know what?
I got to pick up the guitar."
He's just, like, shredding
in like two months.
And Ryder's like, "God."
[ Laughter ]
Taken Ryder like two years
to learn how to play the guitar.
Bing, in, like, a month.
-That's amazing.
You're very lucky
when you know --
when your kids know
what they want.
It's a very sweet thing to know.
-Yeah, it's --
-'Cause my oldest,
his thing is shoplifting,
which has been such a drag.
[ Laughter ]
He's great at it.
We never know
till we get back in the car,
and then he's like...
-Well, you can --You...
[ Laughter ]
You could probably funnel that
into something fantastic.
-I hope so.
We're really --
you know, that's the goal.
So, your oldest --
[ Laughter ]
I know you have three,
just like I do.
And your oldest
was off to college.
Do the younger ones
get very excited
about the homecoming
at the holidays?
-Oh, this Christmas,
it's, like -- it's a thing.
I mean, it's, like, the fact
that Ryder's coming home.
-It's his first time coming home
for Christmas, right?
-It's his first time
coming home.
And even the cousins.
'Cause we do big Christmases,
since we're all together.
And everybody --
I mean, Ryder coming home,
is, like, the big...
-That's really exciting.
-Me, as well,
but I don't want to,
like, be that mom.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know?
-Oh, you can't -- Come on,
you got to be that mom.
Who are you hiding it from?
They know you're excited.
-I know.
-You can't play hard to get
when you're a mom.
Like, "Oh, you? Whatever."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's true. That's true.
-Your mom -- this is very
sweet -- came to the premiere.
Here's Goldie Hawn.
-Yeah.
-Came to the premiere
of "Knives Out."
-Aww, Mommy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you feel any different
watching your work
with a parent around?
-Uhh...
-Like, when you're
at the premiere,
are you kind of checking
to see if she's enjoying it?
-Yeah, especially this movie,
because it's so comedic.
And -- And, I knew
she would love it.
She was far more excited
to see Edward after the movie
than me.
I was like, "Mom, what --
Mom? Mom?"
She's like, "Edward!"
Like everybody, you know --
she was --
But she loved it.
-That's good.
-It's really --
I was, I was --
It's a shame my dad
wasn't there,
'cause Kurt has that laugh.
Like, I remember growing up
and doing plays and everything.
And he was always the loudest
in the room.
And I know, with "Glass Onion",
'cause it's just
such a funny movie,
that in that theater,
he would have -- I mean,
he would have been loud and --
-What do they do
when they don't like it?
Can you tell?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah, totally honest.
Like, they're not --
My parents were
the kind of parents
that, like, when we would
put on a play at Christmastime,
they -- We...
One time, we did one play,
and Kurt, at the end, goes,
"I just don't get it."
[ Laughter ]
We were like -- We were like 6.
And we're like,
"Uh, what do you mean?"
He was like, "I don't get
what's happening.
Like, what's your story?
Guys, there's no middle,
there's no end.
Like, what is this?"
-You got studio notes
on a Christmas play.
-He made us go back
and, like, rewrite our play
and then re-come down
and perform it.
And he had great --
I mean, look, great notes.
-And by the way, he's had
success raising actors.
So you got to give him credit.
-Yeah, I mean...
You know,
it was always like that.
I remember, one time,
he also said, you know,
"Well, honey, there's always
your first movie."
[ Laughter ]
That was his retract
from my first film.
-So, his review
of your first movie was
that it was your first?
-"There's always your first."
-Yeah, no one will ever say
it wasn't your first.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
-I have a lot more
to ask you about.
We will be right back
with more from Kate Hudson.